[Music]
welcome back everyone metro sheriff joe
lombardo joins us now for this week's
morning cup of joe good morning to you
sheriff it's great to see you
can you hear me okay we can hear you
okay thanks for being with us
okay all right we want to ask you this
first sheriff there was recently a
copper theft near the spaghetti bowl
it impacted about 20 light poles there
and this actually was a big problem
during the last economic downturn so do
you see this becoming an issue again
hopefully it isn't but you know in times
of economic downturn
people become desperate and everything
they can
come up with with their demented thought
process
they'll try to perpetrate some kind of
crime time to
fill their pockets but in this case uh
yeah we did
affect two arrests we're still in the
process of this investigation to
determine whether
it's related to the the light poles
there at the spaghetti bowl
um but this is the first of a
of a trend that we are starting to see
again
like you have mentioned from before so
there's there's not a lot of salvage
yards that'll take the copper in
because it affects their license so we
put a lot of
you know stop gaps on the back end of
this to deal with it but now we're
learning that they're taking it out of
state
so there's other states that are
probably not as stringent as we are
and they take advantage of that
opportunity so hopefully
people become more aware of this
particular issue occurring
and they do whatever they can to stop it
or report it
if they see it yeah you know sheriff
unfortunately we've had to talk a lot
about mental health this year because of
the pandemic
is metro responding to more calls
stemming from mental health
or crisis situations i know that you do
often anyway
are you seeing that more often now so
there's been about 19 percent
increase in calls for service associated
with people with mental distress
to include domestic violence there's
been a significant increase
around 17 domestic violence calls
aside from the domestic violence
situations which of course are always
unfortunate are you seeing these calls
lead to other violent
incidents too yeah we you know we've had
a significant increase in
415 a's which stands uh with an assault
with the weapon
year to date in 2020 it's not dissimilar
to what's occurring across the united
states but here in particular it's a
concerning
stat for us and a lot of that is
directly related to the emotional aspect
of domestic violence so um there has
been a correlation with the increase in
domestic violence in 415 a's
and us us having to deal with those
investigations
more often than not now so it's a
troubling trend
we are fully aware of it and we're doing
the best we can with our resources to
address it
all right well sheriff thank you all for
what metro does
all the time we appreciate it and thank
you for being with us have a great
morning
absolutely thank you if you have a
question for sheriff joe lombardo you
can send it to us on our website
8newsnow.com
and find out if your question was
answered every wednesday